the cold war
is uh i think fundamental to the way
people
saw science and math in the soviet union
i don't know if that was true in the
united states but certainly was in the
soviet union
it definitely was and i would love to
hear more about how it was in the soviet
union i mean there's uh
and we'll talk about the the olympia i
just remember
that there was this feeling like
the world hung in a balance and
you could save the world with the tools
of science
and mathematics was like the
superpower that fuels science
and so like people were seen as you know
people in america often idolize athletes
but ultimately
the best athletes in the world they just
throw a ball into a basket so like
there's not
what people really enjoy about sports
and i love sports
is like excellence at the highest level
but when you take that with mathematics
and science
people also enjoyed excellence in
science and mathematics and the soviet
union
but there's an extra sense that that
excellence would lead to a better world
so that created uh
all the usual things you you think about
with the olympics which is like
extreme competitiveness right but it
also created this sense that
in the modern era in america somebody
like elon musk
whatever you think of them like jeff
bezos those folks
they inspire the possibility that one
person
or a group of smart people can change
the world like
not just be good at what they do but
actually change the world
mathematics is at the core of that uh
and i don't know
there's a romanticism around it too like
when you read
books about in america people
romanticize certain things like baseball
for example
there's like this beautiful poetic uh
writing about the game of baseball
the same was the feeling with
mathematics and science in the soviet
union and it was
it was in the air everybody was forced
to take high-level mathematics courses
like they you took a lot of math
you took a lot of science and a lot of
like really rigorous literature
like they the the level of education in
russia
this could be true in china i'm not sure
uh in a lot of countries
is uh in um whatever that's called
it's k-12 in america but like young
people education the level they were
challenged
to to learn at is incredible it's like
america falls far behind i would say
america then quickly catches up and then
exceeds everybody else at the like the
as you start approaching the end of high
school to college like the university
system in the united states arguably
is the best in the world but like what
what
we uh challenge everybody it's not just
like
the good the a students but everybody to
learn in the soviet union was
fascinating
i think i'm going to pick up on
something you said i think you would
love a book called
duel at dawn by amir alexander which
i think some of the things you're
responding to what i wrote i think i
first got turned onto by amir's work
he's a historian of math
and he writes about the story of everest
galwa which is a story that's well known
to all mathematicians this kind of like
very very romantic figure who
he really sort of like begins the
development of this
well this theory of groups that i
mentioned earlier this general uh
theory of symmetries um and then dies in
a duel in his early 20s like all this
stuff
mostly unpublished it's a very very
romantic story that we all
learn um and much of it is true but
alexander really lays out just how much
the way people
thought about math in those times in the
early 19th century
was wound up with as you say romanticism
i mean that's when the romantic
movement takes place and he really
outlines how
people were were predisposed to think
about mathematics in that way because
they thought about poetry that way and
they thought about music that way
it was the mood of the era to think
about we're reaching for the
transcendent we're sort of reaching for
sort of direct contact with the divine
and so
part of the reason that we think of gawa
that way was because gawa himself was a
creature of that era
and he romanticized himself yeah i mean
now now you know he like wrote lots of
letters and like
he was kind of like i mean in modern
terms we would say he was extremely emo
like that's like just we wrote all these
letters about his like floored feelings
and like the fire within him about the
mathematics and you know so he
so it's just as you say that
the math history touches human history
they're never separate because
math is made of people yeah i mean
that's what it's
it's it's people who do it and we're
human beings doing it and we do it
within whatever
community we're in and we do it affected
by uh
the more is this of the society around
us
you